hmm I want you to think back when we had
a look at these all the way back at the
start of term we noticed that anytime
you see something algebraically pretty
much any time you can also represent
that visually and so you know y equals 3
or Y is greater than 3 this equation or
this inequality we can do something
which you may remember we called
plotting on the number lines so if this
was the y number line this guy here
could be the T number line or the X
number line or anything you like if we
said y equals 3 this is our Y here then
to represent y equals 3 this one point
we just put a big fat dot on 3 there we
go
I plotted it ok but when you have a look
at an inequality like this kind the
right hand side Y is not just a
particular number it's a whole bunch of
numbers right it could be 4 or 5 or 8 or
a million or three point zero zero one
and so we indicate that variety
different solutions by not just drawing
a dot what would I actually draw in the
number line for this like now I'm
definitely gonna have an error of some
kind what else am I gonna have along
with that yeah there's gonna be a line
actually strictly speaking this is
called a rave and I'll come back to that
in a second and Gary what are we going
to finish this off with our circle thank
you very much let's piece this together
why is it hollow and not filled like the
original one okay good I'm not including
the actual boundary three but then I'm
like you know what all these other
values this is the an interval started
in somewhere a line goes on forever in
both directions array we don't talk
about them very much but it's not
somewhere that it goes forever in a
particular direction all these values
here on and on and on and on they all
satisfy this inequality so here's the
idea write an inequality there's a bunch
of answers so we draw a whole area there
an equation like this there's like one
spot where it happens now this is just
on the number line but what we're going
to do is we're gonna take this and we're
gonna go from one dimension into two so
now underneath this what I'd love you to
write with me is to consider
let's give an example like this y is
greater than 2x minus 1 and I'm beneath
it because I've got not just a Y or an X
but I've got a Y and an X I need two
dimensions I need a Cartesian plane to
represent this so go ahead and draw for
me an X and a y-axis please hiccups an
iPhone it comes under okay now once
you've got that Cartesian plane look up
and that'll signal for me that you're
good to go
rulers very useful
[Music]
[Music]
okay all right looking good it's okay if
it's not finished can I put you get you
to put your pins down for a minute
if you have not drawn your Cartesian
plane yet that's alright I'll give you
time to do that in a minute so here's my
Cartesian plane with an X and a y-axis
now think back to when we did the number
line just at the top right see this guy
here there's this space that I have
highlighted in which all of the
solutions that I want live right there
four and the five and the million and
the three point zero zero one they're
all on this line okay but importantly
the boundary of this line is this
equation here let me say that again the
boundary that's okay here cups enough on
the boundary of this inequality is this
equation okay so if the boundary of an
inequality is just the same thing but
you put an equal sign in there the
boundary of this inequality whatever it
looks like is going to be this equation
y equals 2x minus 1
when I say equals I get a straight line
right in fact we're going to draw this
on here in a second but importantly this
is the boundary line for this just like
this is the boundary line for this so
draw for me y equals 2x minus 1 but and
it's a bit unusual it's okay it's fine
it's don't feel bad for you what your
body's doing this line here that we're
going to draw could you please draw it
as a dotted line for me
okay draw it in don''t not tell you why
in a second yeah I've drawn this line
dotted and the reason why I'm doing that
is because this is the boundary line
we're used to having dotted lines mean
asymptotes in graphs but they we sort of
run out of ways to indicate what's going
on so we're still gonna use a dotted
line for this now when you have a look
at this first thing right the point
versus this Ray over here the whole idea
is each of these like it's like a whole
bunch of dots I'm just too lazy to draw
an infinite bunch of dots right each of
these dots is a solution to this guy
right Mike was for is a solution Mike
was 5 is solution y equals 6 and on and
on okay
so there's a bunch of values for not
just y but x and y there are solutions
to this okay I'll give you an example
because I need an x and a y together I
think if we put in X equal 0 and also y
equals 0 I think we'll be able to make a
statement out of this and we're going to
work out is it true or is it false is it
actually included in my solutions or not
ok so if I put in x equals 0 and y
equals 0 what is the left-hand side
become 0 right that's the left-hand side
if I don't is going to write left-hand
side equals 0
about the right-hand side what do you
get on the right-hand side you get 2
times 2 times 0 take away 1 which last I
checked it was negative 1 okay now in
this case is the left-hand side greater
than the right-hand side it is right so
in this for this have X in this value I
the left hand side is indeed greater
than the right hand side that's what I
wanted that's what this is right
so in other words x equals 0 y equals 0
where is that on our Cartesian plane
that's the origin right right there
that guy this is a solution to our
inequality just like say that point
there if that was for that would be one
last additions I can find another one
someone want to give me a point that I
can test out an x and a y x equals a
headed one I need a Y to go with it can
someone give me a y-value sure why not
okay let's give it a go what's the
left-hand side go be equal to 1 the
right-hand side it's going to be equal
to when y equals 1 when x equals 1 I
think it's going to be 2 lots of 1 take
away 1 which last I checked was 1
it's okay is the left-hand side greater
than the right-hand side it's not in
this case the left-hand side is equal to
the right-hand side so that's a dog that
doesn't fit my original in a court now
where is that where is one one on here
hmm now one was an interesting point
because if I have this right I think it
is not on this side of the line
nor is it on that timeline I think one
one is on the line itself right and
that's the point that I don't I don't
want it didn't work right so I'm like it
that's not good okay I'm gonna give you
two more and I want you to test just
like I have done right you're going to
get next and why that doesn't sound like
a hiccup to me someone else okay
here's the X and the y that I would like
you to test please let's go with x
equals zero y equals two and x equals 1
y equals negative 2 can you test this
out for me
[Music]
[ __ ] astable focus okay
I've given your new X&Y okay give it a
go I want you to show me the working I
need the working okay
the workings underneath didn't any rule
okay yeah they're in that we had a boy
who had a nosebleed so honor they still
that it's okay alright so we're looking
for an X and a why I want you to put
them in and tell me do the left-hand
side and the right-hand side have the
relationship that we want okay can give
that a go please can you pop these in
pop these in and tell me if you get what
you get from the tent on the right hand
side you get for me
[Music]
[Music]
trick
I'm gonna get to that that's where I'm
going next two and negative one
yep okay this is our first one here x
equals zero or third one actually like
was two I've got two and negative one is
the left-hand side great at the right
hand side
yes so this is a tick so before I move
on to the last one where is x equals
zero y equals two it's going to be x
equals zero I'm going to count up that's
one one two there we go yeah that point
there that one's okay that one's okay
we're going to put ticks beside them
okay and then the very last one x equals
1 y equals negative 2 on the left hand
side it's just negative 2 right it's
just the way they what are you on the
right hand side yeah - lots of one take
away one which is one is the left hand
side great in the right hand side no in
fact it's the other way around you're
like that busted okay where is that
where is that 2 comma negative 1 did I
write the other one oh sorry 1 and
negative 2 so ones are out there now you
have twos been here and that's what
didn't work okay now I could keep on
doing this but as you can see it's a
very time-consuming process do you
notice anything about where the points
are that work and where are the points
that don't work okay yeah you can say it
two different ways you can say see these
points that work fit to the left through
this boundary alone yeah or you can also
say they're above the boundary line
whereas over here you're like this is no
good that's no good it's right on there
if you tested any of these I think
you'll find they don't work right so
just like we did here and we sort of
drew a whole bunch of points all
together if you've got another color
there this will really help I'm going to
shade in
a region that represents all of those
points put together does that make sense
that's just like this line over here so
here's my region it looks like this
Jemaine said to the right or just as
easily rastan said above so any point in
this region actually will satisfy this
inequality okay you can take any X or Y
over here in the X or Y here here here
and it will turn out you'll get a tick
right it's gonna be happy okay now you
remember the beginning I said we drew
this line as dotted and the reason why
is because is this line itself included
two points on the line itself work and
we actually tested one out we like art
doesn't work right so that dotted line
is kind of like the equivalent of this
hollow circle it's like saying yeah all
the way there but not there itself okay
now what I'm likely to try out this is
just with a straight line I start off
with something easy I'd like you guys to
have a look at this this is example two
okay I'd like you to graph or try and
work out what would Y is less than x
squared looks like so I'm just gonna
remember for you how we began this we
drew the boundary what's the boundary
for this inequality this region what's
the boundary going to be it's just the
equation right turn the inequality turn
the inequality into an equation which in
this case would be y equals x squared
that's the boundaries you know what that
looks like go ahead and draw it draw it
dotted because we're not sure if it's
going to be included in the end that
there's a clue to show you that whether
it is or isn't and then just like we did
before find a point test it tell me
whether it works or whether it doesn't
and then see if you can work out where
the region should be okay